[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, thanks for that talk.
That was really, really,
really interesting.
I know at the LHC, there's
been a blip at 750 GV.
Do you have any idea
what that might be?
It might be supersymmetry?
So interestingly, so
I should point out,
because I work on
accelerators, I'm
not part of that
particular collaboration.
So I'm not-- but I do have a
background in particle physics
and I went to a seminar
on that the other day.
So I can tell you
categorically that they
don't know what it is.
[LAUGHING]
Yet.
In fact, they don't
know-- the thing
is about the statistics
of particle physics
is blips can seem to appear.
And then when you get more data,
they can seem to disappear.
So this is an exciting
one at the moment
because it has almost kind
of something like three sigma
significance.
If you've been following, three
sigma is kind of always a hint,
five sigma is
discovery, champagne.
So it's not quite at
the significance level
that we need yet.
So really there, we're
waiting for more data.
And that should
actually be released,
those results, within the next
few weeks I think actually.
So watch the news for that.
It might disappear though.
But let's hope something
else crops up in its place.
Yeah, John do you want
to add to that, maybe?
Or ask something else?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
He's the expert to ask.
No, no.
I don't know anymore,
you said it very well.
No, entirely different,
it was a wonderful talk.
Thank you.
And I'm not an expert
on accelerators,
I just get the data.
So it was really good
to see how they work.
Now I also am aware of people
from the high energy physics
community investing
in plasma wakefield
technologies, not only for
high energy actually but also
further applications.
I just wondered if you
had any comments on that?
Do you think it's a runner?
Should we be worrying more
about that or is it interesting?
Worrying, no.
Supporting, yes.
So plasma wakefield
acceleration is
a sort of relatively
new concept where
you generate a plasma, a
much higher temperature
than this one.
And inside a plasma, the
electrons and the ions
are already broken
down so it can't spark.
And so that can give you a very,
very high gradient accelerating
field.
Now at the moment, the
status of that field
and those experiments
is that they
can generate very, very high
gradient but only over a very,
very tiny distance.
So their not reaching
massive energies,
they're pretty reasonable
for the tabletop
size of the experiment.
In terms of applications,
some of the things
that they will create will
be useful for applications,
especially at the sort
of low energy level.
But the beams they create at
the moment to an accelerator
physicist-- [INAUDIBLE] not
going to mind if I say rubbish.
They have a very large spread
of energy, they're very messy,
they're very unpredictable,
they're very irreproducible.
Shot to shot there's
quite a difference.
That doesn't mean
they're not going
to be really useful for
something application-wise.
It may mean that
you could figure out
how to put different
sections after each other
to drive up to very,
very high energies
and learn to control that.
In my particular field
of high intensity,
it's not something
at the moment that we
can conceive of being
a competitor to a more
conventional type
of accelerator.
But while we're
opening up the field
of different
applications, there's
certainly a place for having
very compact sources that
perhaps could go on
the back of a truck
or out into the field to
widen the applicability
of the machines.
Thanks.
There's a gentleman there
in the white with a red tie.
Just wait for the microphone.
Jane, he's just there.
Is it this gentleman?
I'm a med chemist.
Can you explain to me one
thing that's puzzling me?
In terms of medical
applications,
specifically to
treatment of cancer.
Yeah.
A proton is, what, 1,837
times as heavy as an electron.
Does that mean that a proton
beam has a disadvantage because
of the much higher momentum
of damaging surrounding
non-cancerous cells
compared with an electron
beam or beta rays?
How does it actually stand in
terms of medical applications--
proton versus electron.
So quite the opposite, it
has quite a neat advantage.
You're lucky my
PhD was designing
a machine for proton therapy,
so this is very much my area.
So protons, when they go
into the body, go into water,
they have a very
different interaction
with-- as they go through,
compared to say x-rays.
So if x-rays go in, they deposit
most of their dose on their way
in, and then they're dose rate
falls off as it goes deeper
into the body.
And the same is actually true of
electrons because they're light
and they interact easily.
The protons are heavier,
they have higher energy.
They don't interact as easily.
So they go in and they
don't deposit much energy,
say something like
20% of the dose.
But then the great
thing about protons
is they actually slow down
towards the end of their range.
And that dose level goes up and
you create this peak of dose
at the very end of
the proton range.
And then the protons stop.
And we call this
shape the Bragg peak.
And it's a very well
understood description
in physics of how that works.
So proton beams, you can
actually deliver a higher dose
more accurately,
further into the body
without damaging
surrounding tissue.
And in order to tune
the depth of that peak
and where it lands,
you just have
to change the energy
of the incoming beam.
And these machines are
something like-- to get
about 25 centimeters, which
is the range of most people's
bodies, it requires about 250
Mega electron Volt protons.
So the slight downside
is it requires
a much larger accelerator than
conventional radiotherapy.
But it is a standard
technique now.
Proton therapy has treated
more than 115,000 patients
around the world.
And the NHS are currently
building two full body proton
therapy centers in the UK.
They're particularly good for
childhood cases of cancer,
where you don't want
additional dose in the body
because that can induce later
effects later in their life.
And it's particularly
good for very deep
seated and hard
to reach cancers.
So we will be getting
that before long.
And that's something
that also we're
trying to develop the technology
to shrink down the size
and cost of those accelerators
and improve the treatment
outcome as well.
Thank you.
Nice question.
Can resonances be controlled
by using dampening devices
and so reduce the spread of
a mix of particles in a beam?
Thank you.
Yes.
Brilliant question.
Yeah, that's kind of
the next step, isn't it?
So these resonances,
I kind of only
introduced a sort of
basic form of them.
But they can actually happen
in many different dimensions
with many different
interactions and there
are many different
so-called instabilities
that can build up at different
points in the acceleration
cycle.
Some of those we can
damp with oscillators.
So we measure the oscillations.
We have a very fast
feedback system.
And then some kind of dampening
system tuned to that in order
to damp it back down again.
The ones in the main beam
with that spread of tunes
that I was talking about,
unfortunately if you damp one,
you'll drive another.
So that makes it
slightly more difficult.
But yes, in principle
we are thinking
more about how to use, say,
high frequency dampening
systems to do that.
But some of those take
a long time as well.
So that's-- if you're trying to
accelerate a beam very quickly,
many cycles a second, that
can get in the way as well.
So great question, thank you.
Marcia, is there anyone
up in the gallery?
Because I always forget.
No?
There's one up there.
Or there's a question over here.
Cheeky in the front, here.
A few months ago, we had a
lecture on fusion reactors.
And the gentleman there was
saying that on ITER they
had modified the
field so it doesn't
hit the outside of the toroid
by having a helical field going
around the outside.
And I'm wondering whether
the things you are doing
has any applications
to fusion reactors?
Yes.
So we can't contain our
beam in quite the same way
because it's a much
higher energy beam
and it's much more precise.
But interestingly, on
the other end of that,
there is one very
important application
of high intensity accelerators
related to fusion energy.
In fact, it's vital
for fusion energy
because as these fusion
reactors operate,
they get a huge
amount of radiation
into the walls of the vessel
despite it being contained.
There's a lot of
radiation hitting the side
of the wall of those vessels.
And that causes a lot of
defamation and destruction
of the material that we
don't understand very well
at the moment because
we've literally never had
a device that spat that many--
that much radiation of that
form at those
kinds of materials.
So there's a facility
being developed
called the-- it's IFMIF.
It's the International Fusion
Materials Irradiation Facility.
Yes!
And that's actually going
to take quite a low energy.
It's much, much lower
energy than the ones
I was talking about even,
but even higher intensity
of deuterons usually, because
that simulates the radiation
they're getting off.
And that's such a challenging
accelerator to build.
They're actually building--
their current project
is to build a prototype to even
prove that they could build
the accelerator to do that.
So then they can create
a materials and radiation
facility to try and understand
how the materials in a fusion
reactor are going to behave
when they're actually
in the real deal.
So that itself is
an ongoing project.
Because it's low
energy, they face
slightly different
challenges from the ones
that we do up at the
slightly higher energies.
But yeah, it's a
vital thing for them
to figure out how
to do this stuff
is to also potentially
realize fusion energy.
Yeah.
So I think this is going
to be the last question.
With the catastrophic
political shift that we've had
[INAUDIBLE], I've
got to bring it up.
This is clearly a very
collaborative field
of research.
What's going to
happen in the future?
So, yeah, it is a
very collaborative
and very international
field both in Europe
and all around the world.
So I can't speak for the
future of something like CERN.
CERN is a political
organization,
the UK is a member
state, so I don't
think that will be affected.
However, in the
sciences generally,
a lot of our funding, about
10% of the UK science funding
comes from the EU at the moment.
And so that is likely
to have a large impact.
My institute-- I think,
some of our major projects
are European funded.
In the short term,
of course, we're
told those will continue
to be funded no problem.
But in the future, you
know, it could seriously
impact the progress and
especially the UK's standing.
We lead a lot of these
projects at the moment,
and we may not be
able to in the future.
So I was hoping rather to get
to the end of your discourse,
maybe without that
kind of question.
Someone had to throw it in.
An opportune moment to
actually start clapping again
and [? recognize ?] Susie's
fantastic discourse.
Thank you for so
much for explaining.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.